faire se faire ce point d'étape je pense
que c'était important après presque six
mois maintenant de mise en place de
l'accord
on a vu pas mal de fortes tensions
apparaître aussi bien dans les
haut-normandes que dans les eaux des
hauts de france vous n'êtes pas sans le
savoir je ne vous apprends rien et donc
je souhaitais que qu'on fasse un petit
point à la fois technique sur
l'effectivité le nombre de licences
accordées
parce que c'est un sujet où en sont les
négociations notamment sur eux sur les
quotas à venir
quel est l'état d'esprit nos deux de nos
partenaires britanniques dans cette
affaire alors quelle est l'action de la
commission et bien sûr votre action à
l'âme la ministre assure le ministre par
rapport à la fois la commission et par
rapport par rapport au gouvernement
britannique parce que on sent la tension
monter finalement les dernières les
dernières et récente altercation au
demeurant bien sympathique et
et aux halles en gastronomie qu'entre
premier ministre hansen être président
de la république nous ferons mis à rire
mais finalement sur le sur le fond on
voit que ça ça reste très compliqué et
je met en lien bien sûr à la fois le
sujet de l'irlande du nord mais aussi
les accords désaccords sur la pêche
savoir aussi même si vous êtes exprimé
j'ai lu ce que vous avez dit madame la
ministre monsieur le ministre sur les
moyens de rétorsion que nous avons c'est
aussi important de pouvoir les clarifier
parce que on avait motion de moyens de
rétorsion
vous pouvez être activée dans cinq ans
et demi
c'est tout au moins ce que nous rappeler
régulièrement le commissaire barnier
dans cinq ans et demi au moment où il
faudrait renégocier l'accord
maintenant est ce qu'on est capable
finalement d'activer des moyens de
rétorsion dès aujourd'hui parce que vous
savez vous êtes venus de nombreuses fois
boulogne vous êtes nombreux à l'aide de
nombreuses fois normandie nos
entreprises de pêche reste reste
inquiète et tout comme vous pour nous
élus sur le terrain c'est matin midi et
soir on a des échanges
voilà en gros et jeudi reviendrait sur
des questions peut-être plus précises
après je vous propose que nous avons
alors on ne sait pas quel est votre
temps imparti mais nous on a bloqué une
heure et demie de réunion
je vous propose chacun peut-être sans
rien vous imposez bien sûr un déroulé de
10 minutes chacun et puis après on
revient au point des questions avec nos
collègues qui sont en visio et puis nos
collègues présents ici si ça vous va
très bien merci monsieur le président
madame et messieurs les sénateurs alors
rappelé d'abord vous remercier de votre
invitation je crois que c'était
important qu'on fasse ce point six mois
après à peu près six mois après
la conclusion de l'accord de commerce et
de coopération et notamment de la partie
pêche et de la situation des pêcheurs
français et européens alors concernant
l'accord effectivement de décembre 2020
si nous avons dû faire des concessions
nous sommes parvenus à préserver vous le
savez mon va le rappeler 75 % des
captures en valeur pour l'union
européenne dans les eaux britanniques ce
qui était loin d'être acquis vous
rappeler on avait quand même jusqu'au
dernier moment et jusqu'à quelques jours
du 24 décembre était fortement inquiet
sur la possibilité de ne pas avoir un
accord et puis on a également préservé
les accès et ça c'était aussi important
alors plus en détail moi je souhaite
revenir sur les trois principaux enjeux
de la mise en oeuvre de l'accord et moi
j'ai toujours dit que la mise en oeuvre
de l'accord était tout aussi importante
que la négociation de l'accord et là on
verrait comment tout ça allait se mettre
en application donc on à moi je vous
parlais des
de la mise en oeuvre de l'accord surtout
donc de la gestion des stocks partagés
de l'accès aux eaux britanniques et des
dispositifs d'accompagnement sur la
gestion des stades partager nous sommes
engagés dans la bonne voie je n'aurais
pas dit ça il ya quinze jours mais nous
sommes engagés dans la bonne voie parce
que le 2 juin dernier
il y a eu donc un accord sur les quotas
de pêche qui a été trouvé après plus de
cinq mois de négociations
je rappelle que dans un premier temps
nous avions dit qu'on a un mois tout ça
allait boucler
donc on voit bien du coup comment se
passent les choses alors sur la forme
les rouages sont bien sûr à affiner
parce que la commission européenne
en vue des négociations pour l'année
prochaine doit effectivement jouer la
transparence
et je vous rappelle sur sur la forme
tous les ans nous renégocions ses quotas
donc il était important justement qu'on
réussisse cette première négociation
telle qu'on voulait l'amener parce que
parce que ça va ça a une incidence sur
les prochaines années sur le fond
l'union européenne a été de nouveau
confronté on va pas se le cacher un
partenaire difficile
un cas chercher systématiquement à
s'éloigner de l'application de l'accord
breakes site dès qu'il en avait
l'occasion
bon je citerai par exemple sa volonté de
mettre en place des plafonds sur les
espèces hors quota ce qui n'est pas du
tout prévu à l'accord ou encore sa
proposition de conclure un accord
partiel ce qui était ce qui a été
unanimement rejetée par l'ensemble des
états membres
donc je considère que l'accord conclu
s'il est pas entièrement satisfaisant
parce qu'il reste quand même quelques
sujets et on les a renvoyés au comité au
comité spécial dans lé comité spécial
il reste encore une fois équilibré et sa
grâce à l'unité d'aidé des états membres
c'est à dire en clair à chaque fois
heureusement on a une unité d etat d
etat mans et puis je me félicite
notamment du compromis trouvé en mer
celtique une zone particulièrement
sensible pour les pêcheurs bretons cet
accord du 2 juin va également bien sûr
permettent d'offrir enfin de visibilité
aux pêcheurs et aux entreprises là aussi
j'y suis très attaché au delà de
l'équilibré ce qu'on ait cette
visibilité
cet accord il constitue un premier
palier important pour la construction de
la future relation avec les britanniques
moi j'avais très peur d'un échec il ya
encore quelques quelques semaines
et cet échec aurait été compliqué ça
c'est le premier point nous sommes bien
donc sur cette gestion des sols par des
stocks partagés sur l'accès aux eaux du
royaume uni on m'a donné les chiffres
qui n'ont pas beaucoup progressé depuis
qu'on a déjà échangé est compris dans
une de mes réponses ici dans l'hémicycle
mais c'est le président quand vous
m'avez interrogé
donc on a
tout particulièrement pour les pêcheurs
français oat france normandie et
bretagne travaillé sur plusieurs axes et
d'abord la zone économique exclusive
lazer 2 on a obtenu 739 l'essence
définitive c'est-à-dire 100 % zone
économique exclusive 100% des
autorisations demandées nous ont été
attribués et pour pour avoir une idée
ces autorisations ou c'est l'essence
représente 44% des autorisations
européennes donc on est un gros pack et
quand même nous la france dans cette
danse danse et danse est dans ces
négociations de 2 à 2 c'est une première
chose l'accès des 6 12 mille vous le
savez ces états unis britannique
monsieur le président les hauts de
france en ont une proximité géographique
est très concerné par le sujet et bien
on a reçu on n'a toujours reçu que 88
licences pour les trois régions
cette liste doit être complétée il
manque dans 86 licence toujours demandé
4 40 qui concerne des na'vi remplaçant
la notion de navires en place on on
n'arrive pas complètement se mettre
d'accord
et puis 12 qui se 46 pendant qu'ils sont
des moins de 12 mètres pour les moins de
douze net de 12 m vous connaissez
l'explication par rapport au retard
c'est des vérifications d antériorité de
navires de pêche que la commission
européenne en lien avec le royaume-uni
mène mais ce que je regrette c'est que
systématiquement quand la france apporte
des réponses à la commission à la
demande du royaume uni et bien une
nouvelle demande donc sans cesse en
produits et le directeur de la des pma
qui est ici eric banel pourra le
confirmer sans cesse nous sommes
à la course aux nouvelles demandes
systématiquement tant que c'est ça
devient effectivement un peu un peu
compliqué
je nous travaillons d'arrache-pied pour
y répondre je les dis aux commissaires
nous l'avons dit avec clément bonne nous
sommes prêts à activer tous les leviers
prévu par l'accord pour faire respecter
la loi puisque là on n'est pas au beau
rendez-vous pour jersey nous avons
obtenu rapidement 167 licence provisoire
qui sont valables jusqu'au 30 juin c'est
à dire là aussi la totalité de nos
demandes
c'est bien ça oui il devrait nous
attribuer les licences définitive au 30
juin donc au 30 juin une fois transmis
et valider les licences définitive si
toutefois certaines ne devait pas nous
parvenir dans les temps parce que devait
être là aussi appelés à apporter des
justificatifs complémentaires et bien
nous demanderons un décalage de cette
date du 30 juin ça se passe bien dans
l'ensemble avec jersey sur sur garneau
est perdant sur jersey vous savez la
situation est compliquée là aussi on
avait on souhaitait demander 344 les
licences nous avons
pu fournir des données sur 272 donc au
final notre demande a été 2 272 licence
à ce jour on en a obtenu 47 définitive
et vous vous rappelez le 30 avril
dernier
et vous vous rappelez la surprise que
nous avons eue d'avoir que 47 licence
sur 272 mais que en plus ses 47 licence
comporter ddd décision complémentaire
des restrictions complémentaires
arbitraire qui n'avait pas été notifié
en avant par les autorités britanniques
sapouy nous avons nous juger français
qu'on n'avait pas les éléments pour a
demandé et 344 licence donc sur les 315
à 6 ans demandés par les pêcheurs nous
avons avec la dpm a regardé avec les
professionnels regardez l'ensemble des
documents que nous avions pour justifier
effectivement ces licences et s'avère
que nous avons au final film demandé 272
semble c'est la demande que ça arrivait
à jersey c'est dû à quoi c'est dû à
l'absence de documents qu'on vous avoue
même fourni c'est l'absence de
justificatifs que ses 344 navire en fin
de compte
péché déjà et avait déjà des droits dans
la zone 2 de jersey en clair avant nous
avions plus d'autorisation que deux
bateaux allaient pêcher
c'était la corde de la baie de granville
savait toujours d'ailleurs été un motif
de frottement entre jersey est et et les
français c'est ce qu'on a plus des
quotas de papier ou des licences de
papier c'est comme ça qu'on les appelle
c'est à dire on en avait mais on
n'allait pas là l'accord à signaler
l'accord dit
pour y aller il faut avoir de
l'antériorité et donc faut démontrer
l'auteur de l'antériorité nine y avait
une intérieure théréau été démontré que
pour 272 donc lance aujourd'hui gens qui
ne peuvent pas posséder une licence qui
n'étaient pas utilisés
mais détail sans doute c'était des
licences à pied on appelle ça des quotas
de papier ou des licences papier c'est à
dire on les avait mais s'empale est tout
à fait tout l'intérêt quand on a ce type
de données de quotas ou de licences
d'aller pêcher ainsi compris d'ailleurs
pendant six ans mais quand on voudra
revendiquer nos droits
bon ça c'est le petit qui conseille et
il n'y a pas que sur ce sujet qu'on
devrait effectivement aller chercher
l'ensemble de nos quotas ou du moins
essayer d'occuper les honneurs
bon donc sur ses 47 licence sur le
cadeau sur les 272 on a eu 47 licence
sur ses 47 licence il était mentionné
des restrictions non prévu par l'accord
c'était des limitations de nombre de
jours c'étaient des zones qui étaient
effectivement limités j'ai donc
annoncé que nous n'étions pas du tout
d'accord donc là on l'a signalé la
commission qui a signalé au royaume uni
nous l'avons signalé à jersey également
et j'ai donc pu dire plusieurs fois que
pour moi ces éléments étaient nulles et
non avenues et je le répète encore ici
ce n'est pas acceptable tel que ça si ça
c'est ça c'est fait je comprends et je
partage les aspirations des pêcheurs
normands et bretons qui exercent leur
activité depuis fort longtemps pour
certains dans la baie de granville et
qui se disent ça se passait bien avec
nos voisins au camp avec des voisins
sari doit pas toujours être d'accord
mais ça se fait ça se passait bien
aujourd'hui on peut plus parler il faut
que jersey par le royaume uni qui parle
à la commission qui parle à la france
qui parle de ces pêcheurs bretons
normands concernés sauf que c'est comme
ça c'est l'accord qui qui a été mis en
place dans le royaume il a décidé quoi
pour jersey parce que c'est le royaume
uni même si jersey s'exprime c'est le
royaume uni c'est que les licences
définitive sur les licences définitive
les contraintes serait levée jusqu'au 30
juin est applicable au delà du 30 juin
c'est la décision du royaume uni
deuxième décision pour les licences
restait provisoire c'est à dire la
différence entre 47 et 272 seraient plus
calculées sur les licences restait
provisoire par manque de données et bien
de renouveler cette période provisoire
là aussi jusqu'au 30 juin nous y sommes
donc quelques jours
moi pour ma part j'ai demandé parce que
je dis depuis le début on voit bien que
les délais qu'on ces données n'ont
jamais été respectées d'aller beaucoup
plus loin
j'ai demandé au commissaire européen de
d'obtenir du royaume uni une
prolongation de tout ce système jusqu'au
30 septembre voire même au 1er janvier
2022 parce que je pense qu'il nous faut
du temps
il faut noter il nous faut du temps pour
faire baisser la pression ou alors il
nous faut du temps pour décider ce que
nous faisons véritablement mais en même
temps j'ai également demandé que ce qui
est prévu dans l'accord breakes site de
pouvoir actionner
alors j'ai perdu je me suis perdu en
route c'est pas grave j'ai retrouvé de
pouvoir actionner la possibilité de
faire travailler le royaume uni et la
commission sur un nouvel accord pour la
baie de granville qui serait plus
équilibré et qui bien entendu se ferait
avec le comité le conseil de partenariat
puisqu'il s'appelle le conseil de
partenariat c'est une possibilité que
nous avons c'est l'instance tout à fait
l'instance qui permet à la france face
aux à la commission et au royaume uni de
pouvoir négocier pour jersey un autre
cadre et donc ça c'est important pour
les gouvernements où on pourrait revenir
lévis j'ai constitué ma parité
évidemment il est représentant européen
le représentant britannique se conseille
de partir assez l'organe de gouvernance
politique de l'ensemble de l'accord qui
ensuite déclinaison un sectorielle et il
s'est réuni pour la première fois la
semaine dernière du côté britannique il
est
pilotée par le ministre david frost est
chargé des relations avec l'union
européenne et du côté européen par le
vice président de la commission monsieur
sefcovic
et puis ensuite il ya des délégations
paritaire de chaque côté avec avec à
chaque fois un contrôle les états
membres avant et après pour le côté
horrible non alors il ya ensuite les
comités spécialisés
ça c'est le regard général politique qui
traite par exemple en ce moment
difficultés sur la pêche ou sur le
protocole sur sur la pêche
bien entendu là aussi je pense et
l'ambition reste reste simple c'est
remettre en place les équilibres et les
automatismes des accords de l'abbé qu'en
ville on en a besoin
ma vision de l'europe ccc c'est
justement que on puisse avoir un bon
voisinage qui se fasse entre les régions
françaises et les îles anglo anglais
normande
moi je quelqu'un de pragmatique je crois
qu'on sera davantage efficace et ça
évite la division non il faut être deux
voir faut être quatre
pour pouvoir y parvenir et puis le
dernier point c'est la réserve
d'ajustements briques si tu sais comment
effectivement et clément bonne parlera
de la réserve d'ajustements pour exciter
moi je vais parler de plan
d'accompagnement qui a été qui sera
financé dans le cadre de cette réserve
100 millions d'euros réservée à
l'accompagnement de la filière pêche
c'est 100 millions d'euros vont
accompagner l'ensemble de la filière
c'est un plan qui est désormais entrées
en vigueur
il était attendu pour les pêcheurs c'est
des aides
qui se matérialise par des arrêts
temporaires indemnisés à 70% du chiffre
d'affaires
j'ai obtenu que ce dispositif soit
prorogé au second semestre 2021 et pour
les pêcheurs et les marieurs cette fois
qui n'auraient pas eu recours aux arrêts
temporaires durant cette période et qui
sont dépendants des eaux bien sûr ou des
stocks partagés avec le royaume uni est
bien un dispositif de compensation d'une
partie des pertes du chiffre d'affaires
sur le premier trimestre a été mis en
place soit 12 millions d'euros pour 12
millions d'euros pour les pêcheurs et 8
millions pour les mariés voilà mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs en première
introduction pour conclure bien entendu
avant de laisser mon collègue clément
bonne compliqué et compléter je voudrais
dire aux dire qu'avec dans le cadre du
brics it on est entré dans un nouveau
monde mais il est pas question que cette
entrée dans le nouveau monde
nous fasse lâcher nos encore youri tno
antériorité nos droits et et je crois
qu'il faut effectivement que l'on parle
d'héritage des pêcheurs français camp
revendique 7 cet héritage donc s'ouvrir
sur le sur une nouvelle pêche sur un
monde nouveau mais avec notre héritage
en caux construisant bien entendu avec
les professionnels avec les britanniques
cette nouvelle relation
moi je je je travaille en toute
transparence
je co construit avec mes partenaires et
c'est donc bien sur ma manière de
travailler et je continuerai à le faire
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
ministre je suis très heureux de revenir
aussi devant votre commission pour un
point spécifique sur ce sujet ô combien
sensible de la pêche annick jardin déjà
développé longuement dont je ferai
quelques remarques complémentaires avant
qu'on puisse répondre à des questions et
préciser l'ensemble des points
je veux dire d'abord que nous sommes ce
que vous l'avez fait monsieur le
président je prends un pas de recul sur
l'ensemble de la relation
franco-britannique euros britannique et
la question du break site nous sommes
dans un moment extrêmement difficile
nous savions ni jardin l'a rappelé que
la mise en oeuvre de l'accord seraient à
beaucoup d'égards plutôt si compliqué
sinon plus que la négociation de
l'accord qui est le même on s'en
souvient a mis 4 ans a été un test de
souveraineté de fermeté et d'unité
européenne que nous avons réussi sous le
pilotage de michel barnier et nous
devons maintenant réussir l'application
de notre côté nous le faisons au delà de
la question de la pêche
nous avons chacun fait des efforts
j'assume cet accord comme l'a fait
l'ensemble du gouvernement comme l'a
fait le prendre la république il faut
être assemblés en a été informée nous en
avons discuté c'est un bon accord y
compris je le dis sur la question de la
pêche même si le brix il crée forcément
des difficultés mais les difficultés ne
peuvent pas être ajoutées à celles que
nous avons négocié de bonne foi en
connaissance de cause en toute
transparence avec les professionnels
dans l'ensemble des élus sur la question
de la pêche et nous sommes aujourd'hui
dans un moment où nous avons une
préoccupation très vives parce que la
partie britannique ne respecte pas
intégralement complètement cet accord
c'est vrai sur la question de la pêche
nous avons recensé annick girardin les a
rappelés ensemble de difficulté précise
mais importante et c'est vrai et cela
nous concerne aussi sur la question du
protocole nord-irlandais qui je le
rappelle n'est pas un élément technique
mais est un élément central du
dispositif d'ensemble des accords de
retrait et de commerce que nous avons
quand je dis nous c'est l'ensemble des
européens
et bien sûr les britanniques négocier
voter selon nos procédures
parlementaires ratifié désormais et il
faut être je crois très très clair sur
ce point parce qu'il ya aujourd'hui j'y
insiste à cette occasion beaucoup
d'intox dans la position que le royaume
uni relais et la façon qu'elle décrit
l'attitude et la position de l'union
européenne et notre relation je crois
mérite mieux que cette intox
pardon de le dire en anglais mais c'est
peut-être l'occasion le spin qui nourrit
jour après jour les médias britanniques
et parfois européen l'union européenne
ne fait pas preuve d'intransigeance ou
d'inflexibilité ne prenne la république
l'a rappelé à l'occasion du g7 crois que
plus flexible que la patience nous avons
fait preuve c'est difficile une
britannique ont faire un choix
nous l'avons respecté car c'est un choix
souverain et démocratique
mais nous avons passé y compris avec
anidjar dans la dernière ligne droite
des dizaines ou des centaines d'heures
ici même au parlement dans les
négociations a cherché à trouver le
meilleur accord possible et trouver le
meilleur compromis possible car ce sont
des compromis donc on ne peut pas dire
que la souveraineté britannique n'a pas
été respecté l'union européenne n'a pas
cherché la négociation on nous reproche
même parfois le contraire d'être trop
obsédé par la recherche des compromis
omnium dans l'union européenne moi je
l'assumé comme j'ai dit mais on ne peut
pas dire qu'on a été intransigeant et
aujourd'hui les questions que les
difficultés qui sont recensés sur
l'application du protocole les contrôles
y compris sur ces points l'union
européenne a aussi cherché à tout moment
les solutions pragmatiques
je prends un exemple les contrôles
sanitaires et phytosanitaires
monsieur sefcovic que j'évoquais au nom
de la commission européenne et de
l'union européenne a dit à plusieurs
reprises qu'ils étaient prêts trouver
des modalités de contrôle simplifié qui
permet de limiter 80% des contrôles qui
sont aujourd'hui effectués au titre de
ce fameux protocole donc y compris dans
les derniers jours l'union européenne a
été d'une patience une flexibilité plus
que remarquable et donc nous attendons
maintenant de la part des britanniques
autre chose qu'un mauvais récit une
application stricte des engagements pris
c'est évident sur la pêche c'est évident
sur le protocole et la fin d'une forme
de triste comédie qui consiste à accuser
l'union européenne de créer des
difficultés en irlande ou en irlande du
nord nous sommes viscéralement attachés
au respect d'accords à tout ce qu'il
implique
sur le plan politique sur le plan
territorial on le sait sur la question
de la pêche et plus encore sur la paix
en irlande
nous sommes prêts à continuer à discuter
mais que les choses ne soient pas
inversés c'est l'application du côté
britannique nous demandons j'insistais
parce que franck il faut rétablir aussi
au moment nous parlons six mois après la
conclusion de l'accord la réalité
quelques remarques simplement sur la
question spécifique de la pêche
annick girardin l'évoqué à l'instant la
question parce qu'il ya quand même des
bonnes nouvelles
houssin a notamment de ce que nous
faisons dans l'union européenne la
question de la réserve d'ajustements
d'ajustement sur le break site vous le
savez c'était un point essentiel de
l'accord du break site entre pays
européens de notre accord budgétaire que
nous avons conclu l'été 2009 1,5
milliard d'euros était réservée à
limiter les impacts économiques du
brésil notamment dans les régions qui
sont très concernés par la pêche et dans
les régions frontalières ou proches au
royaume uni qui sont les plus impactées
cela vaut pour les autres france là haut
pour plusieurs régions françaises
il a une proposition de la commission
nous avions eu l'occasion d'en discuter
au sénat qui ne convenait pas
du point de vue français parce qu'elle
ne prenait pas en compte je ne rentre
pas dans les critères détaillés nos
intérêts et nous impact économique
nous avons trouvé notamment parce que la
france s'est mobilisée à tous niveaux à
tout moment un compromis qui est je
crois bon prend en compte l'essentiel
nous intérêt économique avec une
enveloppe et en euros courants dépassent
700 millions d'euros pour la france
nous sommes dans un moment où
aujourd'hui même un trilogue comme l'on
dit se réunit entre le parlement
européen la commission le conseil pour
finaliser je l'espère ce compromis
je suis optimiste sur le fait que nous
resterons dans l'ordre de grandeur que
nous décrivons et que la proposition de
la commission initial sera donc revue à
la hausse pour la france et nous aurons
encore à discuter ensuite des modalités
précises de répartition l'argent
arrivera à partir de la fin de l'année
il permettra de soutenir ou d'amplifier
le cas échéant les dispositifs nationaux
que la ministre de la mer rappelait et
dont je souligne aussi comme la famille
jardin qu'ils ont été validés par la
commission européenne pour le coup dans
un temps très rapides par notre
mobilisation aussi et si cela permet
d'ores et déjà sous le contrôle a
légèremment d'apporter un soutien au
secteur
cela était le deuxième engagement de
soutien avec la réserve est justement de
réussite que nous avions le premier
ministre à g lors de son déplacement à
boulogne indiqué donc cela nous le
mettons en place
cela ne veut pas dire bien sûr que nous
pouvons lever la garde sur la délivrance
des licences je n'y reviens pas je crois
que la mise de la maire a fait le point
le plus complet possible sur l'état des
lieux ainsi que sur l'accord positif
cette fois ci encore ça arrive du 2 juin
concernant les tac je veux dire aussi
que nous aurons à continuer cette
mobilisation pour la délivrance des
licences qui n'est pas satisfaisante
un ninja raynal a dit un peu plus de 90
ans qui manquent encore aujourd'hui et
cela a été évoqué à l'occasion du
conseil de partenariat que je
mentionnais il ya un instant réponse à
votre question monsieur le président qui
s'est réuni le 9 juin qu'il était du
côté européen par le vice président de
la commission monsieur sefcovic
il n'a pas évoqué seulement la question
de la pêche mais il a mis tout en nous
préoccupe à sion et de nos
revendications
l'application des accords sur la pêche
nous avons dit sur ce sujet comme sur
les autres qui pose aujourd'hui problème
que nous étions prêts à poursuivre les
procédures que nous avons engagées très
concrètement l'accord lui même prévoit
des mesures de réponse de rétorsion si
certains engagements comme ceux que l'on
a évoqué ne sont pas respectés et donc
nous allons en parallèle cela a été
évoqué si la situation ne s'améliore pas
si la situation ne s'améliore pas car
nous souhaiterions évidemment ce serait
plus simple plus efficace plus apaisé
pour tous notamment pour nos pêcheurs
que la succession s'accélèrent et se
règle mais si cela n'était pas le cas
nous sommes prêts à poursuivre la
procédure que nous avons engagées qui
peut devenir donc une procédure
contentieuse contre le royaume uni à
saisir le tribunal arbitral pour
contester pour constater si le
manquement aux accords se poursuit la
violation des accords et prendre même
entre temps si cela était nécessaire des
mesures de rétorsion cela ce sont les
outils que nous avons en main je le
redis
ce n'est pas une menace c'est un fait
prévu par l'accord nous n'inventons pas
ces outils et c'est un recours en cas de
difficultés persistantes mais c'est pas
quelle est la définition exacte de la
persistance enfin force est de constater
que les choses commencent à durer et
vous le savez comme nous au mieux que
nous monsieur le président sur le
terrain notamment la france l'impatience
légitimement montrent donc nous
n'hésiterons pas à activer ses leviers
que j'évoquais qui sont prévues par
l'accord pour défendre nos intérêts dans
les semaines qui viennent si cela était
nécessaire
marcel kovic a évoqué la gravité de la
situation avec son homologue david frost
et rappeler que nous avions à ces outils
à notre disposition
je dis calmement mais solennellement
nous n'avons jamais hésité cela n'était
pas gagné à faire preuve de la plus
grande fermeté la plus grande unité
européenne tout au long de la
négociation de l'accord nous le ferons
aussi parce que cela fait partie des
engagements pris et de leur respect
nécessaire à faire preuve de cette
fermeté et de cette unité
cela a été rappelé notamment par les
dirigeants européens en marge du g7 au
premier ministre d'une seule par les
prochaines semaines si cela était
nécessaire
un mot sur le processus et la
gouvernance simplement pour répondre à
la question vous posez tout à l'heure
dans la gouvernance qui est prévu donc
il ya ce conseil de partenariat qui est
l'organe central si je puis dire
transversale des vocations des
difficultés à résoudre ou des mesures à
prendre
et puis il ya des comités spécialisés
dans un comité sur la pêche qui pourrait
se réunir dès le mois de juillet
justement pour traiter des difficultés
que nous connaissons à la demande de la
france l'est prévu par l'accord les
états membres du côté européen peuvent
accompagner la commission européenne ils
sont en tout cas évidemment informés et
associés même en amont comme en aval des
discussions entre le royaume uni et pour
répondre précisément être question
monsieur le président oui c'est une
demande que nous avons formulées
et la commission l'a indiqué les
professionnels du secteur ou toute
association professionnelle non
gouvernementale peut être consultée
pendant ou avant les négociations avec
le royaume uni sur le sujet comme la
pêche est évidemment centrale et puis
des états membres eux mêmes
c'est notre responsabilité celle d'annie
girardot tout particulièrement peuvent
avant lorsque nous échangeons en tant
qu'etat membre avec la commission faire
toutes les consultations qui sont
nécessaires et que nous faisons
évidemment je veux simplement dire un
mot sur la praye 2026 parce que j'espère
vivement que nous allons surmonter nos
difficultés du moment
je ne veux pas ajouter un problème un
autre mais il est sur notre devoir nous
allions parler moment de la conclusion
de l'accord de préparer la suite
simplement pour rappeler qu' il ya une
inquiétude que nous connaissons sur la
prêts dans le secteur de la pêche parce
que quand même tout serait bien
respectée aujourd'hui cela ne vaut que
pour cinq ans et demi nous devons d'ores
et déjà réfléchir un défense nous
intérêt à la visibilité que nous donnons
aussi la filière de la pêche pour la
suite
simplement pour rappeler que nous avons
des outils en main ce point j'espère
encore une fois que la situation sera
apaisée que nous pourrons engager une
négociation peut-être y compris
bilatérales avec le royaume uni pour
définir les paramètres de la presse
mais les britanniques auront en effet en
main la possibilité de restreindre ou
dans un cas extrême d'empêcher l'accès à
l'eau après 2026 mais cela ne peut pas
se faire à leurs mains seul il y à des
mécanismes à notre main d'européens de
mesures compensatoires de mesures de
rétorsion dans le secteur de la pêche ou
ou d'un autre secteur que nous pouvons
automatiquement activée cycle et
britannique souhaitait imposer ce type
de restriction ou d'empêchement l'axé
exactement au même moment au même moment
en miroir c'est très important parce
qu'évidemment ça fait réfléchir avant
d'envisager cette possibilité que nous
ne souhaitons pas mais qui est
légalement possible que les britanniques
limites ou empêchent l'accès à leur jeu
et donc je rappelle un dernier levier
dans ce paquet qui est à notre main il y
à aussi vous le savez une partie
sectorielle plus ciblés parce que sinon
nous parlons de mesures très fortes qui
est la partie énergie de l'accord qui
sera renégocié également 2026 dans le
même pas de temps et donc nous mettrons
aussi en regard les intérêts
britanniques les intérêts européens pour
ses accès après 2026 en fait tous les
éléments de l'accord sont renégociable
en 2026 selon alors il y à des possibles
alors voilà donc ma question est ce
qu'il ya des moyens d'amendé
d'amender l'accord si effectivement rien
contre ça n'a pas l'air d'avoir des
processus des procédures pardon
d'amendements de l'accord d'un commun
accord entre les parties selon les
procédures qu'on a suivi pour les
négociations initiales ont négocié la
pêche pourrait en faire partie
théoriquement mais cela serait compliqué
mais ça ne le sait pas est-ce que c'est
pas envisagée au regard des difficultés
qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est possible je
pense que là bas un enjeu de l'urgence
si je puis dire quelle application
pleine et entière de l'accord et la
période jusqu'à la mi 2006 on peut
imaginer cela mais je crois que les
mécanismes qui sont en place nous donne
un équilibre dans la renégociation
puisque les deux façons il faut que les
britanniques disent qu'ils veulent faire
après 2026 et s'il nous disait j'espère
que non mais c'est possible on ne veut
plus vous ayez accès à l'eau après 2026
ou dans des proportions extrêmement
limité c'est à ce moment là que nous
disons mais à ce moment là réfléchissez
bien parce que nous nous pouvons sur le
secteur de la pêche sur d'autres
secteurs m les mesures supplémentaires
et le l'ensemble de l'accord peut-être
soit amendée soin de dénoncer dans un
cas absolument extrême à tout moment par
l'une des parties alors al'inverse c'est
une question dont je connais à peu près
la pons mais pour mes collègues
est importante c'est de se dire
finalement quel la réciprocité des
anglais par rapport aux licences que
nous on pourrait leur accorder
à pêcher dans les 6 12 milles et est ce
que est ce qu'il ya ce qu'il ne reste
libre au site et kid qui est envisagée
en ce sens c'est un jour où le dire mais
finalement puisque vous nous ennuyer
chez vous on va vous ennuyer je la suive
quatre ont projeté de précis dans les
réponses
il ya une réciprocité qui n'est pas une
parfaite symétrie puisque nous le savons
c'est pour ça que avec annick girardin
nous avons toujours été très ferme dans
la négociation initiale sur le fait que
si on isole elle secteur de la pêche
évidemment on donnait puisque
britanniques ont six fois plus d'accueil
de pêcheurs que de pêcheurs dans les
eaux européennes et donc évidemment ils
ont un avantage tactique et de
négociation et donc si on isole et la
pêche on était forcément perdant c'est
pour ça qu'on a toujours mis ensemble le
paquet mais même dans le secteur de la
pêche le contrôle d'un jardin nous
pouvons prendre des mesures internes à
cette filière c'est à dire des droits de
douane par exemple sur les produits de
la mer quand on sait très bien que les
britanniques en sont dépendants à
l'égard de notre marché mais je crois
qu'il faut toujours garder la logique du
paquet parce que sinon c'est d'ailleurs
pour cela que nous avons demandé que la
pêche soit inscrite à l'ordre du jour du
conseil de partenariat global parce que
sinon les britanniques en poche les
avantages qu'ils ont et n'applique pas
on le voit sur d'autres sujets les
contraintes ce qu'ils ont dans notre
domaine donc on doit garder tout ça mais
lier la réciprocité même interne au
secteur de la pêche
forcément un peu déséquilibré et puis
des mesures de rétorsion qui peut être
plus large et dépasser le secteur de la
pêche
jusqu'en mai auront la renégociation
affaire on la négociation à faire
eh bien nous mettrons en balance ce que
vous leur et faire les britanniques dans
le domaine de la pêche est ce que nous
pourrions imposé dans notre domaine pour
qu'ils y réfléchissent avant d'aller
vers cette position extrême ce qui se
passe parce qu'il s'est bien passée dans
dans la mise en oeuvre
c'est le volet à deux et c'est très
clair les britanniques ont à peu près
1000 navires sur dans les autres
européenne aujourd'hui mais ils n'ont
pas de 6 12 milles hier qu il n'est pas
pêché dans aucune de ninon zoni autre c
ou smic donc on voit bien c'est à dire
quand on voit bien que là où il ya des
intérêts britanniques et bien les choses
se sont bien passées on à la totalité de
nos demandes
100 % des demandes on faisait 2 et là où
c'est des droits historiques mais qui
n'allait que dans un sens c'est à dire
que seule la fin pas seul mais enfin des
européens venaient dans les 6 12 milles
et notamment les français sur les côtes
britanniques et bientôt n'y a pas de
réciprocité voilà il ya la volonté de
montrer des exigences ou des décisions
qui vont au delà de l'accord moi je
rappelle toujours c'est l'accord est un
que l'accord nous devons être
respectueux de cet accord et nous et
nous le ferons mais on a un partenaire
sur ces sujets qui est difficile je le
redis et c'est vrai que c'est là où faut
qu'on soit hyper vigilant parce que
parce que qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
pour pour dans sa dent dans cinq ans sur
ce sujet moi je prends un petit exemple
exemple des des navires
remplaçants on n'arrive pas à se mettre
d'accord sur la notion de deux navires
remplaçant
ça veut donc dire que si on se met pas
d'accord on pourrait arriver à ce qu'on
appelle
deux compères le la clause du grand-père
bronze grand père c'est à dire
abandonnez qu'on perde nos droits parce
que tout simplement le droit est attaché
un navire qui écoute et vieux coup qui
ne veut plus pêcher ou voilà et donc
l'ati faut qu'on fasse hyper attention
sur les équilibres de la négociation
avec nos droits danser dans ses eaux
voilà je crois pas qu'il y ait quelque
chose à rajouter de particuliers sur ce
que savait dit peut-être on peut
répondre à d'autres questions
merci madame et messieurs les ministres
pour la qualité et la précision de vos
réponses et puis aussi pour la
détermination dont vous nous faites
preuve pour faire appliquer vous l'avez
dit un tout l'accord rien que que que
l'accord en étant tout à fait conscient
comme vous l'avez dit madame la ministre
une nouvelle page s'ouvre dans où
s'écrit dans la relation avec nos amis
britanniques est bien évidemment celle
ci doit se faire sans renier nos droits
ancestraux
je voudrais d'abord faire peut-être une
petite remarque c'est vrai que c'est une
bonne nouvelle que
au delà de 2026 il n'est pas uniquement
que le volet pêche mais que à part ce
moment où il ya le volet énergétique
l'interconnexion des réseaux etc
ça peut être 100 employés de deux gros
mot mais ça peut être je dirais un moyen
de pression
d'une certaine façon alors je sais pas
s'il ya d'autres sujets qui au delà de
l'énergie peuvent peser dans la
négociation ça serait important que vous
ne puissiez le préciser et puis j'ai
peut-être de 3 trois petites questions
la première c'est vrai que sur la
gestion des stocks partagés l'accord est
arrivé le 2 juin entre le 1er janvier et
le 2 juin il ya quand même une période
de zones grises si on peut employer
cette expression on sait que la
détermination des quotas c'est compliqué
parce que s'il ya des évaluations
scientifiques etc etc
alors pour 2022 et les années suivantes
et est-ce qu'on peut envisager une date
qui est qui serait largement j'ai la
plus proche de de l'année calendaire
la deuxième question que je me permets
de vous poser concerne donc la
renégociation du grenville des accords
de la baie de granville 2 si on pourrait
employer sinon combien de temps ça
demandait ce qui serait possible de
faire coïncider si je peux employer
cette expression le
le granville 2 avec le maintien de des
autorisations provisoires
c'est peut-être un peu trop idéaliste et
puis le troisième c'est la réserve
d'ajustements dont vous avez parlé des
12 plus 8 millions sur les sens j'ai cru
comprendre que cette réserve est
justement l été sur une période 2021 à
donc est ce que vous pouvez me confirmer
l'annualisation si on peut dire de de
cette mesure de compensation très bien
plus répondre d'abord on a c'est
l'article 500 de 4 qui nous permet de
modifier les dispositions relatives à
nos relations avec les îles anglo
normandes
c'est l'option donc nous avons
privilégié on demande ont effectivement
que y ait des relations plus équilibrées
avec nos voisins de jersey et donc de ré
ouvrir une discussion et de pouvoir
poser les bases d'un conte ville 2 si on
veut les appeler de cette manière parce
qu'il faut qu'on soit davantage
équilibré j'ai aussi fait la proposition
parce que on est bien sur la gestion des
stocks et cette gestion des stocks
qu'elle a besoin
là aussi d'avoir un éclairage
scientifique plus important que celui
qu'on a jusqu'à aujourd'hui j'ai demandé
au commissaire de d'impliquer l'europe à
ce niveau de recherches et de données
scientifiques dont on a besoin de
manière à ce que ce soit neutre comme
éléments puisque je cherchais n'a pas
les mêmes elles mêmes moyens de
recherche que nous pouvons avoir par
exemple avec ifremer ou même si on a
déjà mené des actions ensemble ça reste
effectivement un partenaire français et
donc on a demandé
que ces débats enfin c'est c'est eh oui
c'est des débats ces échanges puissent
se faire aussi avec un éclairage
scientifique qui devait se réaliser donc
moi j'attends aussi la réponse le plus
vite possible parce que c'est ça les
restrictions sur les zones les
restrictions sur
sur la période c'est lié à une meilleure
gestion des ressources de jersey bon
c'est sans doute dans la baie de
granville un des lieux où les pêcheurs
ensemble ont bien cogérer la zone
bon donc véritablement un travail sur ce
sur ce volet-là et donc il faut que le
conseil spécialisé de la pêche dès le
mois de juillet puissent effectivement
travaillé sur ce sur ce sujet avec des
objectifs d'atteindre un accord pour
pour la fin de l'année si nous y
arrivons mais vraiment pour l'instant
nous n'avons aucune réponse de la partie
jersey ou au royaume uni de notre
demande de s'asseoir pour pouvoir y
travailler et on est vraiment dans la
tente de la réponse du 30 juin c'est à
dire on va arriver au 30 juin avec
qu'est ce qu'ils ont décidé puisque je
n'ai pas de réponse non plus sur les
périodes d'attentes
le temps de cette négociation que
j'avais demandé jusqu'en septembre et
plus à mon avis logiquement pour avoir
une bonne négociation jusqu'en décembre
c'est à dire la 1er janvier 2022 pour la
mise en place de ces deux sets de ce
nouvel accord sur le plan oui c'est 2021
à 2025 le plan d'accompagnement donc
nous rappellerons régulièrement
effectivement les moyens mis en place
j'ai demandé l'autre jour quels étaient
les moyens d'adaptation après des outils
c'est toujours un travail que nous
pouvons mener avec la commission c'est à
dire le plan a été validé tel qu'il
était c'est un plan qui résulte d'un
travail de plusieurs mois avec les
professionnels certes si l'évolution
nécessité qu'on a effectivement
retourner vers la commission pour dire
bon il ya des modifications qui sont
aussi parce que la réalité du terrain
c'est plutôt ça ou plutôt ça on verra
bien et on peut toujours le faire
aujourd'hui les outils sont en place et
les pêcheurs actuellement avec les
services concernés remplissent les
dossiers de demandes de compensation ou
ou dead
qu'est-ce que je n'ai pas dit
voilà fazi jeu pendant j'ajoute un mot
pour être tout à fait précis en
complément sur la réserve d'ajustements
briques site un jeu parfois les les
montants qui circulent sont un peu
embrouillé donc c'est l'occasion de
clarifier donc c'est 672 millions
d'euros pour la france
en europe on l'appelle le constant et
quand on les traduit en euros sonnants
et trébuchants
en prenant en compte l'inflation mais ce
qui sera donc versé concrètement c'est
plus de 700 millions 713 millions
d'euros pour la france sur la période
concernée comme les a ni jardin ça
jusqu'en 2025 en cohérence avec notre
propre plan d'accompagnement et très
précisément donc il ya quatre cinquièmes
de l' enveloppe qui seront versés en
trois tranches
on appelle le préfinancement m'enfin en
fait celle de financement entre demi
entre désormais 2021 prolonge vers la
fin de l'année et 2023
trois tranches qui a pris 1 81% de l'
enveloppe de notre enveloppe que
j'évoquais est le 4è 5è le cinquième
5ème par non 20% restants seront versés
avant 2025 d'ici 2025
donc les 100 millions c'est bien
l'enveloppent annuelle 1 qui sera
renouvelée et là au moins je je me dis
qu'il faut être humble peut-être les
outils devront peut-être évoluer les
sommes on attendra toutes les
confirmations dagne de la négociation
actuelle du président obama miss
ministre je suis sénateur alsacien dont
vous avez compris que 1 par la pêche à
la truite
je suis pas spécialiste à tout le mois
du dossier pêche mais vous avez bien
compris que c'est un dossier qui doit
préoccuper la totalité du sénat comme
l'assemblée nationale est bien entendu
de l'exécutif
moi mon interrogation essentielle est la
suivante le l'accord sur le bric sites
comme vous l'avez dit a duré assez
longtemps pour qu'effectivement on visse
les uns et les autres s'en félicite et
on a toujours considéré naturellement
que la pêche méritait un traitement à
part on a bien vu à quel point c'était
difficile d'aboutir à cet égard mais cet
accord il constitue un tout voilà et et
moi ce qui m'étonne c'est que de plus en
plus on a tendance à considérer que
c'est un accord dans un accord que laver
la pêche la pêche est un accord dans un
accord et on a un peu le sentiment que
mon il faut trouver un accord absolument
sur la pêche encore il faut il faut
faire preuve de patience il faut même
j'ai même entendu re négocier
éventuellement cette partie d'accord moi
je peux peut-être parce que je suis
alsacien et qu'en alsace on est plutôt
jugulaire jugulaire est plutôt
disciplinés
moi je dis que
c'est juste pas acceptable d'entendre ce
type de discours visant à permettre au
royaume uni de prendre la décision qu'il
veut sur une partie de l'accord je me
fais ici d'entendre naturellement le
gouvernement faire preuve de deux à la
fois de patience et de volonté
persuasion mais aussi de fermeté à cet
égard moi je voudrais que vous me
parliez de la position de l'union
européenne dans sa globalité de tous les
pays tout particulièrement la commission
je sais bien que vous avez un
commissaire européen vient pas ce qui
m'intéresserait c'est de savoir quel est
le degré de solidarité de l'union
européenne dans un dossier naturellement
de ce type bien est ce que est ce qu'on
peut attendre de l'union européenne
des positions fortes sans attendre 2026
enfin moi 2020 6 essais l'un c'est loin
c'est partir du moment où c'est un
accord global qui a été l'accord éxiste
qui a été signé dans les conditions dont
on a parlé on se tient cet accord on se
tient cet accord et les 26 ont-ils la
volonté d'abord en ont-ils les moyens de
rétorsion je parlais tout à l'heure de
rétorsion en quoi est ce que ces moyens
de rétorsion sur la pêche seulement où
est-ce qu'on peut comme on a prévu de
faire en 2026 déborder sur d'autres
termes de l'accord et 10 rebonds mais
finalement écouté si vous voulez pas
appliquer ça on pas appliquée l'autre
non plus et qu'on soit tous d'accord sur
le fait que même si ça ne concerne pas
la france je dis n'importe quoi les
allemands puissent intervenir sur tel
aspect de l'accord que les royaumes
signé tout à fait désireux d'appliquer
ou non les allemands pourrait dire ne
pas la cour du tout moi je considère
vous l'avez compris que c'est un dossier
qui ne doit pas être traitée à l'aune
d'un triumvirat
royaume uni france ait commis c'est et
commission avec un commissaire en plus
qu'il eut bien mais que c'est c'est un
accord c'est un dossier qui doit te
traiter entre l'union européenne le
royaume uni dont la france est partie
voilà voilà donc ma question c'est celle
ici qu'est avez vous le sentiment comme
ça je sais pas quand on n'est pas en off
ici mais là où le sentiment que l'union
européenne l'union européenne et
solidaire voilà constitue un blog et
qu'on se dise voilà mais on nous sommes
prêts à aller au clash on va pas laisser
la france dans cette auberge comme ça on
va pas juste retraité sa commission
européenne j'ai rien contre la
commission mais on voit bien que sans
intérêt c'est aussi de faire en sorte
que ça marche bien sûr bon est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment que dans cette
affaire on
on est solidaires au niveau de l'union
européenne parce que si on l'était pas
ce serait pour moi c'est grave
dans ce cas là il faut il faut se poser
des questions voilà le sénateur la
réponse est oui je n'ai pas de doute sur
la solidarité européenne
ce qu'ils ont fait depuis 2016 le pari
de la division européenne et de
faiblesse européenne et tant mieux se
sont trompés qu'elle souhaite un défi
c'est clair on est un club de 27 et la
négociation du mexique a été une forme
de miracle européen c'est une mauvaise
nouvelle le brix et on l'a toujours dit
ça n'est pas bon non plus pour l'union
européenne je pense que c'est encore
moins bons à long terme pour le royaume
uni mais quand il ya eu la question de
la pêche dans la négociation quand
arrive la question du protocole
irlandais quand d'autres pays avaient
des intérêts spécifiques sur la
communauté de leurs citoyens au royaume
uni beaucoup de pays de l'est de
l'europe où la france à chaque fois il y
avait des cas particuliers et nous avons
réussi par le mandat commun par la
négociation à leur conduite par michel
barnier a conservé cette unité
européenne
je les dis je le redis je crois que
c'est très important cela a été un test
de souveraineté nous l'avons réussie
nous devons réussir à nouveau ensemble
test de souveraineté qui nous est posée
maintenant car nizon le franchement je
pense que certains l'ont de croire que
l'europe va se diviser et qu'ils peuvent
en effet choisir les aspects de l'accord
qui leur plaisent délaissé ce qui ne
leur plaisent pas et que l'union
européenne ne réagira pas a fortiori en
choisissant des logiques de ciblage la
pêche à l'égard des français mais aussi
le protocole à l'égard de l'irlande
même si ça nous concerne tous gt il y a
quelques semaines en irlande avec jean
yves le drian nous avons passé ce
message commun de fermeté et c'est un
message européen prend 2 exemple très
récent pour que chacun s'en convaincre
maros sefcovic levis prendre la
commission en charge des intérêts
communs
a été extrêmement clair et ferme sur ces
points la pêche et le protocole en
particulier lors de la discussion avec
david frost il y à moins d'une semaine
lors du g7 s'étaient pas un sommet avec
l'union européenne mais il y avait
d'après ans de la commission européenne
le président du conseil européen
plusieurs dirigeants européens dont le
train de la république la chancelière
allemande le prendre conseil tient tout
ce monde y compris d'ailleurs peu plus
loin de nos latitudes le président
américain on premise britannique
il faut respecter tous d'accord et dans
la corse n'est pas une méthode de voyou
c'est une méthode de droit dans l'accord
il y à des mesures de rétorsion soit sur
un secteur particulier la pêche par
exemple soit pour justement garder cet
équilibre d'ensemble sur d'autres
secteurs comme je l'évoquais après 2026
ou maintenant si les engagements ne sont
pas respectés
je ne fais pas de surenchère ou une
polémique c'est pas nous qui les faisons
mais nous avons puisque vous
m'interrogez c'est normal je le dis nous
le disons que membre du gouvernement
devant la représentation nationale
nous ne défendrons les intérêts français
et européens qui sont imbriqués et nous
pouvons aller intérêts spécifiques qui
nous concerne évidemment avec plus de
force d'émotion ou d'engagement comme la
pêche
mais ce sont des intérêts européens et
j'ai le souvenir encore du dernier
sommet européen où nous ne savions pas
au moins de novembre
si au moins d'octobre annonce il y
aurait encore un accord sur le break
site il ya moins d'un an
on pensait qu' il n'y avait plus que la
pêche à négocier et le prendre la
république a dit avec d'autres la pêche
ne sera pas dissocier du reste parce que
nous négocions en tant qu'européens cela
n'a pas été le cas et nous avons défendu
jusqu'au bout
l'accord y compris avec ses bonnes
mesures au total sur la pêche maintenant
nous aurons la même fermeté la même
unité la même détermination
dans l'application je le dis les deux
sont vrais ceux qui disent que l'union
européenne pour royaume uni aujourd'hui
ne font pas preuve de flexibilité on a
fait preuve d'une flexibilité qui va
parfois jusqu'à la contorsion pour
trouver des solutions pour aider pour
coopérer c'est notre intérêt à long
terme à tous mais cette flexibilité ça
n'est pas du laxisme et donc la division
ça ne marchera pas
le test de faiblesse ou de division ne
marchera pas si c'est ça que certains
ont commis des ça n'est pas la vérité de
l'accord et ce n'est pas la vérité de la
position européenne
ça n'est pas une lubie française ou une
focalisation sur nos intérêts aussi
important soit-il
nous négocions en bloc jusqu'au bout
dans la négociation on l'a fait dans
l'application le ferons il faut être
très clair là dessus je crois que je
peux confirmer effectivement fermeté
unité des pays européens c'est vrai
qu'il faut en être conscient on a huit
états membres concernés par la pêche
mais derrière c'est l'ensemble des pays
européens qui se sont mobilisés dans la
négociation de l'accord et quand
toujours soutenu ces huit pêcheurs face
et hugues pays pêcheurs et ça continue
et je crois qu'il faut on voit on le
voit dans l'ensemble des rencontres ont
pu avoir lieu depuis un mois depuis plus
d'un mois systématiquement et ils vous
parlez du commissaire européen
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus que le
commissaire européen mais nous avons
effectivement fait appel au vice
président manos sefcovic qui lui a
repris le rôle et puisqu'il est chargé
de l'application de l'accord
c'est son rôle en tant que
vice-président de suivre cette dessus
cet accord on va bien maintenant que on
est passé à autre chose que simplement
le commissaire et je fais quand même
félicité le commissaire bien entendu qui
se bat tous les jours comme d'ailleurs
la dg merle a démarré assez cad à ses
côtés
ils sont offrant tous les jours mais ils
sont plus seuls et ça c'était important
et en tant que ministre de la mer nous
on a toujours été on a toujours formé un
duo avec avec clément parce que parce
que c'était la force de notre équipe
c'est d'être sur les tous les francs et
fallait y être et bien quelque part
c'est c'est même ça même volonté a lieu
dans plusieurs pays européens et il ya
véritablement une dynamique on le sait
on a des amis aussi très fâché l'irlande
bien entendu question de l'espagne
l'italie les pays-bas plusieurs pays
effectivement montent au créneau sur un
certain nombre de sujets c'est pas
toujours sur les mêmes espèces pas
toujours sur les mêmes zones donc on
entend pas on pense pas obligatoirement
parler nous les français nous parlons de
nos difficultés
bien entendu mais mais mais chacun
rencontre dans les négociations aussi
d'aider des difficultés et nous avons
affirmé j'ai affirmé même si c'est un
peu étonné ou choqué qu'il y avait des
mesures de dissuasion et que nous
allions les utiliser alors effectivement
mesure pêche donc droits de douane sur
les produits de la pêche qui pourrait
effectivement rentré en france et c
c'est une action qu'on peut qu'on peut
mener sur toutes les autres marchandises
d'ailleurs que nous pouvons avoir c'est
bien entendu la question de l'énergie on
l'a vu ça va être négocié en même temps
que les accords de pêche donc on a un
autre levier mais mais plus largement et
vous l'avez dit à l'extrême c'est la
remise en question tout simplement de de
cet accord et pas seulement que de la
pêche commerce pêche transport aviation
simultanément nous pouvons effectivement
avoir ce cette force cette force
d'action ouvrés pour des raisons qui
leur appartiennent moi j'ai l'impression
que les britanniques jouent la montre
et se disent au delà effectivement de la
difficulté de la mise en place ce qu'on
va faire là sera le modèle pour pour
2000 2026 et donc eux aussi en tout cas
intérêt de leurs positions à faire en
sorte que la moindre négociation les
engage deux mois possible
[Musique]